The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
hello and welcome.
No particular announcements
today other than,
in the unrelenting
tradition of MIT,
we're going to forge
straight ahead, and keep
going with new material.
Today, we're going to talk
about frequency response.
And just to set the context,
remember that last time we
talked about a way to
characterize a system,
in terms of a single signal.
By knowing the impulse
response of a CTE system,
you could characterize
the response to any system
by thinking about the
response to any signal
by thinking about the output as
the convolution of the impulse
response with the input signal.
And that gave rise to a
very compact way of thinking
about the output of a system.
We think about the
output y as being
x convolved with h, regardless
of whether it's dt or ct.
And the way that you
carry out that convolution
is, in fact, very similar
in the two systems.
That way of thinking
about a system
is particularly useful for
certain kinds of systems.
The examples we looked at
last time were optical.
In the case of an
optical microscope,
it's very convenient to
think about the effect
of the microscope is
to blur the target.
So whatever the target was,
it always comes out blurrier,
and that blur function is
something that in optics we
call the point spread function.
The point spread
function in 6003 terms
is simply the three
dimensional impulse response.
We can think about three
dimensions very similar
to the way we think
about one dimension.
And in fact, in the next
homework assignment--
which amazingly enough
is already issued.
So in the next
homework assignment
we'll think about two
dimensional signal processing.
And the difference between
one and two is not very much,
and the difference
between two and three
is even less than the
difference between one and two.
So we'll be able to think
about an optical system
purely in terms of
the impulse response,
and that's particularly useful,
because it's so intuitive.
Since the effect of the
optical system is to blur,
the impulse response is a direct
measure of how much it blurs.
That's true, not
only for microscopes,
but it's true for
optics, in general.
Imaging with light, it's
a fundamental principle
that derives from the
wavelength, the coherent nature
of light.
And here's an example taken
from the Hubble Space Telescope,
where we see that there
is much more blurring
from a ground based microscope
than there is from the Hubble,
simply because the blurring
is the result of two things.
Generally speaking, if you
have a ground based system then
there's two kinds of blurring
that we usually think about,
blurring to the atmosphere
and bouncing off
particles in the
atmosphere, and blurring
due to the optics, the same
as it was in the microscope.
By going to space, we completely
eliminate the blurring
in the atmosphere,
and so we're left
with what can be a much
sharper point spread function.
Today, we're going to look
at a completely different way
of thinking about a system.
Rather than thinking, what we
will call in the time domain,
h of t was a function of time.
The impulse response
was a function of time.
We think about that as time
domain signal processing.
Rather than thinking
about the time today,
we'll think about
the frequency domain.
Frequency domain,
just like time domain,
is very convenient for certain
kinds of signal processing
tasks.
One very natural
example is audio.
You all have lots of
familiarity with this.
What I'm going to do
now, to prove to you
that you have
great intuition, is
I'm going to play
a clip followed
by the same clip processed
in four different-- in two
different ways.
All right.
Clip-- so original clip 2.
And clip 1 and clip 2 will
have some transformation
applied to it.
Either the high frequencies
HF or the low frequencies LF
will be increased up arrow
or decreased down arrow.
OK?
Is that clear?
So I'm going to first play of
the original, then play clip 1.
You should decide
whether the clip 1
sounds like the high
frequencies are increased,
the high frequencies
are decreased,
the low frequencies
are increased,
the low frequencies are
decreased, or none of those.
Then I'll play the original
clip 1, original clip 2.
So there's going to be two
answers, what happened to clip
1, what happened to clip 2.
OK.
Nod your head yes, everybody
knows what's going to happen.
OK, now everybody listen.
So you're supposed figure out
two different answers, what
happened to clip 1, and
what happened to clip 2.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK.
What happened?
Answer 1, answer 2, answer
3, answer 4, answer 5,
raise your hand.
Come on, come on, come on.
This is the part that you
blame on your neighbor.
OK, no don't.
Talk to your
neighbor, that way you
can blame it on your neighbor.
Yeah, I forgot that part.
OK, talk to your neighbor.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
OK, everybody raise your
hands what happened,
and if you're wrong just
blame it on your neighbor.
Just point to your neighbor
as you raise your hand, right,
and I'll understand
what you mean.
OK, you're only
about a half right,
you're supposed to
be young people.
I'm old, I'm not supposed
to understand these things.
So you're about half right.
So now let's see maybe
I can do it again.
So listen again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, now the answer
is perfectly clear.
Everybody raise your hand.
What's the answer?
OK.
I know the problem.
The problem is-- does
anybody know the title
through this piece?
AUDIENCE: No.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
That's the problem.
It's 1970s, I wasn't thinking.
This was new in 1970.
I heard it when I was in--
but anyway.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
DENNIS FREEMAN: The answer was.
The answer is that one.
OK, so the high frequencies
in clip one were increased.
If you heard sort of a
tapping in the background,
kind of a symbol
thing that was louder,
because the high
frequencies were enhanced.
In the second part, it
sounded sort of similar,
except the volume was lower.
That's because I killed
the low frequencies.
OK.
So in the first part the high
frequencies were increased.
In the second part the low
frequencies were decreased.
And I'll assume that if I
had done the updated music,
you would have got that.
So I assume that you all got
100% correct, and we'll go on.
So the-- yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about when you say
increasing degrees [INAUDIBLE]?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes, you do.
AUDIENCE: And what that
include the amplitude
when you say increasing degrees?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Will be
a little more clear--
So the question was, when I
say increasing degrees, what
exactly do I mean by that.
What I meant was the
magnitude of the frequency
components was increased.
We'll be saying-- we'll be
developing some language,
in the next 40 minutes, that
will make that statement more
precise, OK.
So the idea here was to give
you an intuitive feeling
for something that will
make mathematically
more rigorous as we go along.
By the end of the hour it
should be completely clear
what I mean by high frequencies
increased or low frequencies
decreased.
If it's not tell me.
So the idea then, in
frequency analysis,
is to think about the
input as frequencies.
Think about the input
being cos omega t,
and then think about
what the system
would do to a signal that
was of the form cos omega t.
We'll find out, as we
go through the hour,
that the signal that comes out
of a linear time invariance
system, when the
input is cos omega t,
is also cos omega
t of frequent--
it's a signal with
the same frequency.
However, the amplitude
and the phase--
that which sort of
addresses your question.
The amplitude and the
phase can be different.
Linear time
invariant systems can
change the amplitude and
phase, but not the frequency
of a pure sinusoid.
So then the trick in
thinking about what
linear time the invariant
system does, to a sinusoid,
is thinking about how's
the magnitude to change,
and how's the frequency change.
So motivate that a
little more, well, I
want to think about mass,
spring, dashpot system.
We talked about this before.
If I think about the
input of the system
being the position of
the top of the spring,
and if I think about the
response of the system
being the position
of the mass, then I
can characterize that system as
a linear time invariant system.
And I can think about how
does the amplitude change
and how does the phase change,
as a function of frequency
of the sinusoid.
OK, this is just like
the music example,
but this time it's mechanical.
And what I want to do
first is do a demonstration
of figuring out the frequency
response for a physical system.
OK, so here's my
mass, spring, dashpot.
Hopefully, you can all see that.
It is 10 loops of a slinky
connected up to a bolt.
And the idea is that
I want to characterize
how does the magnitude
of the response change,
as a function of
frequency, and how
does the phase of
the response change,
as a function of frequency.
So if I turn it on
to a low frequency--
[MOTOR BUZZING]
OK, so I've got a low
voltage going to the motor.
The motor has got a cam on it.
The cam's turning, that's
giving the sinusoidal motion
up and down.
If you have very
good eyes, you should
be able to see this a
little knot in the string
is going up and down,
that's my input.
Because the cam is not
changing physically,
as I change the
speed of the motor,
the amplitude of the
sinusoid won't change,
but the frequency will.
That's the idea.
OK, so what you're
supposed to do
is this is x and that's y,
how would you characterize
the magnitude of the response
as the ratio of the magnitude
of the input, the output?
They're the same.
So the magnitude for this low
frequency, the magnitude is 1.
How about the phase
relationship between the two?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: They're
in phase with each other.
Right, when one goes up,
the other one goes up.
So at these low frequencies,
the magnitude starts out at 1,
and the phase starts out at 0.
Now I'll increase the speed.
[MOTOR BUZZING]
Now what?
What's the magnitude?
Up, up, down, don't
have a clue, don't care.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK,
it's up a little bit.
So the magnitude
is up a little bit.
How about the phase?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: It's
kind of similar.
I'll just put a big dot.
OK, so now I'll turn up
the speed a little more.
[MOTOR BUZZING]
AUDIENCE: I think the
magnitude might have changed.
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
Up or down?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Yeah, went way up.
So it came up here
someplace, right.
How about the phase?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
It's totally-- it's
going completely out of phase.
So the phase-- in fact,
we will call that a lag,
but that's not
perfectly clear now.
We'll see later why I'm
going to call it that.
What do you think will happen
if I go further higher?
Hit the roof, right.
So if I go-- so
this is 4 1/2 volts.
If I go to a higher frequency--
[MOTOR BUZZING]
Ooh, funky.
Why is it funky?
AUDIENCE: Out of sync.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Out
of sync of what?
It's only got one input.
How can it be out of sync?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
it's remembering
some of the response
that it had before.
Right, so I really have to wait
for the old response to die.
If I were to kill the
input, it wouldn't
stop moving right away.
Right, so it's-- so the response
to the previous input is
interfering with the response
to the current input.
If I wait long enough,
it ought to settle down.
OK, magnitude up or down?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Compared to one?
It's still down.
It's down even compared to one.
How about phase?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So it's
almost out of phase.
Out of phase would be
the top is going up,
while the bottom is going down.
So it's almost out of phase,
so there's even more delay.
OK, so that's the idea.
So that's-- what this is
supposed to motivate is why we
like to think about systems in
terms of frequency response.
It's a natural way to think
of certain kinds of systems.
Just like the time response,
the impulse response,
the time domain
thinking convolution,
was a convenient way to think
about some kinds of systems,
the optical system.
Frequency response is
a good way to think
about some kinds of systems.
Here's one.
The reason it's a good
way to think about it
is that this particular
system had a big response
at a certain frequency.
OK, now for something that
has nothing to do with 003.
Why is the CD there?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: It keep
it-- so it somewhat
stabilizes it, that's correct.
AUDIENCE: See it better?
DENNIS FREEMAN: See
it better that's true,
but then I should've
put one up here too.
But of course, who
knows, I make mistakes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Damping.
What's damping?
So damping controls
how big the amplitude
got at the resonance frequency.
Without the CD, it went crazy.
Right.
In order to get the
response to be less
than the elongation
of the spring,
I had to make the
displacements tiny, tiny, tiny
without the CD.
So the CD was putting
some damping--
air resistance.
OK.
Loss-- So in physics terms,
the mass and the spring
are lossless, no
energy goes away.
I'm continuously pumping
energy into it from the motor.
The response gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger.
With the CD, there's loss,
because of viscosity loss
to the air.
And so that means that it
doesn't reach as high a peak,
as it would have otherwise.
OK?
OK.
So now what I want
to do is think
about having measured it, let's
think about calculating it.
Let's calculate the
frequency response.
We have a number of
ways we could do it,
because we have
all those boxes, we
have all the
different methods we
thought about for
characterizing systems.
So for example, we could figure
out the differential equation
for the system, and
we could solve it
with a particular
input, cos omega t.
That's one way to do it.
Another way we could do
it is find the impulse
to the system--
the impulse response of
the system, and then we
could convolve.
Right, we're all very familiar,
we could do all those things.
So rather than doing something
we know how to do, what I'll do
is something that we
don't know how to do.
I'll use a different
method, which
has to do with eigenfunctions
and eigenvalues.
And we'll see why
that's a convenient way
of thinking about frequency
response in just a minute.
So we'll be define
in eigenfunction
to be sort of the same thing
as we do in linear algebra.
So it's very much
the same concept.
We think about if
we have a system
and if we put in an
input, and the output
has the same shape as the input,
just changed in amplitude,
then we will say the input
was an eigenfunction.
And the change in amplitude
was the eigenvalue.
So you put in x of t,
you get out then x of t.
Same idea that we have in
linear algebra for eigenvalues.
OK?
So that's the idea.
And it turns out that
certain very common functions
are eigenfunctions of linear
time invariant systems.
Consider this system,
y dot plus 2 y is x.
Figure out if any of these
functions, e to the minus c,
e to the t, e to the
jt, cos t, or u of t.
Are any of those functions
eigenfunctions of that system?
And the answer is
yes, and so the answer
is really which ones?
So how do I think about
is e to the minus t
an eigenfunction of that system?
What should I do?
Let's think about--
how many think it is?
How many think it isn't?
OK, it must be, right.
Crowdsourcing, it
has to be true.
So how do I think about that?
How could I set that up to
convince somebody else that it
is or is not an eigenfunction?
What would I do?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Close.
So what should I make x be?
AUDIENCE: So you make
x be either negative t
or make y be
[INAUDIBLE] negative t.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Exactly.
So then y dot would be--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
now if I plug that in,
I get y dot minus
lambda e to the minus--
e to the minus t plus 2 y plus
2 lambda e to the minus t,
should be e to the minus t.
Is that true for any lambda?
What should lambda be?
1.
So the answer is
yes, this is true,
and lambda would have to
be 1 for that to be true.
How about this guy?
Same thing, lambda
comes out the same?
What's lambda for
the second line?
AUDIENCE: 1/3.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1/3, yeah.
So now we have to use
x is e to the t lambda
e to the t lambda e to the t.
Did I do that right?
Yeah.
So now we have lambda
plus 2 lambda e to the t,
should be e to the t.
So lambda's going to
have to be 1/3 this time.
OK.
How about this guy?
What's lambda?
AUDIENCE: 1 over 2 plus j?
DENNIS FREEMAN: 1 over
2 plus j, exactly.
Everybody see that?
How about cosine?
Yes, no, I'd like
to break the tie.
So there's a tie, the yes's
and the no's are equal.
So what do I do?
You do the same thing,
right, no difference.
Oops, a little too hard.
So I want to say
that x is cos right.
So y should be lambda cos.
So y dot should be--
lambda sine minus, right.
So then I need y dot
minus lambda sine
t plus twice, this
one, lambda cosine t,
should be that one, cosine t.
What should lambda be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Complex exponentials.
So if you're willing to somehow
think about something over here
is imaginary, maybe
you can do that.
If you think about these
as purely real functions,
there's no real--
there's no way to take a
cosine and turn it into a sine.
That's actually why we like
the complex numbers, right.
Had we thought about the
cosine as the sum of these,
if we had thought about cosine
t as e to the j t plus--
minus j t by 2, if we had
thought about it that way,
it would have
actually turned out
that we could think about
the complex exponentials
as being eigenfunctions.
But the cosine function
itself, thought of it
as a strictly real
function, there's
no way you could choose
the constants to get rid
of the phase shift that would
be introduced by the sine.
OK, if we call the
phase of this 0,
this is phase shifted 90
degrees relative to that,
and there's no way that I
could choose a real number
lambda to make that
come out with 0 phase.
OK.
How about u of t?
Im function?
Same thing, right.
I would think of
the input is u of t,
the output is lambda u of t,
the derivative of the output.
If the output is lambda u
of t, what's the derivative?
Lambda delta.
So I'm left with trying
to make a lambda--
left with trying to
make a u function out
of the sum of a delta
and a u, and there's
no way you can do that.
So the answer is that the
first three are eigenfunctions,
and the last two are not.
OK.
So now what's this have to do--
I mean, I set this
all up by thinking
about frequency response.
So what we want to do is make
the connection between the two.
The first step in the connection
is complex exponentials,
just like I'm
motivated here, right.
So the complex exponentials--
so it turns out that
all complex exponentials
are eigenfunctions to all
linear time invariant systems.
That's kind of amazing.
That follows very directly
from what we did last lecture.
If we think about a linear
time invariant system
as having an impulse
response, then we
can find the response
to the system,
with the impulse response h
of t, by convolving h of t
with the input, which is
a complex exponential.
So if I say that my
input is e to the st,
and that my response
is characterized
by the impulse response h of t,
all I need to do is convolve.
So I convolve h,
whatever it is, with x,
which is e to the minus st.
You remember that
when you convolve,
you do the funny
things with the axes.
So instead of thinking about e
to the s t as a function of t,
I think about it as the
function of t minus tau.
Instead of thinking about
h of t as a function of t,
I think of it as h of tau,
and I run an integral.
And because of the special form
of the exponential function--
which is no coincidence.
Because of the special
form of the exponential
function the e to
the st factors out.
So then I'm left with something
that the integral, the function
of tau, the taus all go away.
I'm left with purely
a function of s.
And in fact, it's
extraordinarily friendly.
If I put in e to the st into a
linear time invariant system,
characterized by h
of t, then the output
has the shape e to the st,
and the eigenvalue is h of s.
Amazing.
It's the value of the system
function, the same thing we've
been doing since
week two, evaluated
at the s that is the exponent
in the complex exponential
of interest.
In my opinion, that's
wholly remarkable.
Then, knowing that we
can form sinusoids out
of complex exponentials,
the problem is done.
All complex exponentials
are eigenfunctions
of all LTI systems.
And I can write--
I can always write
an eternal sine wave
in terms of a
complex exponential,
by using Euler's expression.
And so I'm done.
Furthermore, the eigenvalues
that I need to do this
are trivial, they're the
value of the system function.
That's even easier in the
case that the LTI system
can be written as a system of
partial differential equations
with constant coefficients.
When that is true-- that
is not all-- that is not
true for all LTI systems.
What I've said with
the convolved part,
that's true for all LTI systems.
If I specialize it to the
case that the system can
be represented by a
linear differential
equation with
constant coefficients,
then the system
function is always
a rational polynomial in s.
It's always the ratio
of two polynomials in s.
The reason that's interesting
is that we can factor it.
is that each of those factors
has a very simple
geometric interpretation.
So what-- so if I can represent
the LTI system in terms
of a system of linear
differential equations
with constant coefficients,
then the transfer-- then
the system function
has to shape,
has the form of a
rational polynomial in s.
By fundamental theorem in
algebra, and by the factors
here, I can factor it.
Makes it look like that,
and then each of these terms
looks like a vector
in the s plane.
Difference between two complex
numbers, that's a vector.
So for example, if I
wanted to think about--
here's a system, a
single pole at minus 2.
Say I wanted to find the output
when the input is e to 2 j t.
E to the 2 jt is a
complex exponential.
The system is linear
in time invariant,
therefore I know that
the complex exponential
is an eigenfunction.
Therefore, all I need to
do is find the eigenvalue.
The eigenvalue is the
value of the system
function at the s in question.
So all I need to do is
look at this diagram,
and I have the entire picture.
The system is a single
pole at minus 2.
That's the x.
I want to know the response when
the input is e to the j 2 t.
So the s in question
is s equals 2 j.
So it's that point right there.
So all I need to know is
the length and direction
of the vector that
connects the pole
to the frequency of interest.
The length of that vector is 2
route 2, the angle is plus 45.
It's a pole, so
that contributions
in the denominator.
So the eigenvalue
is 1 over the length
of the vector, because it's
a pole, and minus the angle,
because it's the denominator.
Is that clear?
Point is it's really easy
to do, that's why we do it.
We only do things in this
class that are easy to do.
And you can then
divide and conquer.
If you have a system that's
linear time invariant, that
can be represented by a
system of linear differential
equations constant coefficients,
rational polynomial s factor,
do it for each factor.
Do the same thing I just
did for each factor.
The magnitude of the response
is the product of the magnitudes
of each of those parts.
The angle of the
response is the sum
of the angles of
all of those parts.
So the idea is that
it's very simple.
One last step-- if I'm
interested in eternal
of sine waves, like I was
for the motor example, then
I'll always be interested,
according to Euler,
in two complex exponentials.
So if I were interested
in cos omeganaut t,
I would be interested in
the complex exponential e
to the j, omeganaut
t, and e to the minus
j omeganaut t, because I need
both of those in order to sum--
to get the purely real
function cos omeganaut t.
So that means then, I
can write the response
to this eternal cosine wave as
simply the sum of the system
function evaluated at j omegnaut
times e to the j omeganaut t,
and the system of
function evaluated at s
equals minus j omeganaut times
e to the minus j omeganaut t.
Done, I have the answer.
It's even easier, because
the system function
has a symmetry that we
call conjugate symmetry.
That's easy to show
also by convolution,
that's why we did
convolution before we
did frequency response.
You can prove the properties
of a frequency response
by resorting back
to convolution.
Convolution is a very
powerful thought tool.
Less powerful as a
computational tool,
very powerful thought tool.
So here again, if we think
about the system function
is the Laplace
transform of h of t--
you remember that
from two lectures ago.
System function is always the
Laplace transform of h of t.
If I have a physical
system, like the mass spring
dashpot, h of t is real,
how could it be complex.
H of t is the response when
I have a particular input.
The response of a
real system is real.
So if I have a system that
is real, then h of t is real.
If I'm interested
in frequencies that
are the negative of each
other, plus or minus
j omeganaut in order to
form cos omeganaut t,
then I'm interested in two
different system functions,
h of j omega and h of
minus j omega, which
happen to be complex
conjugates of each other.
Since the h of t is real--
I just argued that for
a physical system h of t
has to be real.
If h of t is real, then the only
j in this equation is that one.
It's negative here, so
therefore negating j
is the same as taking
the complex conjugate.
So I don't really have to
compute two different system
functions, two
different eigenvalues.
One is the complex
conjugate of the other.
That means that the response
to the sum simplifies.
So if I want to
think about the input
for-- if I want to think about
the input as an eternal cosine
wave, cos omeganaut
t for all time,
I write that by Euler, this way.
I know from this eigenvalue
eigenfunction idea
that the response to this
guy can be written this way.
It's a complex exponential.
Complex exponentials are
eigenfunctions of LTI systems,
so it has the same shape
in an eigenfunction--
in an eigenvalues, sorry.
This one can be
written similarly,
except there's a minus sign.
Because this is the
complex conjugate of this,
and this is the complex
conjugate of that,
I've got the sum of a number
and its complex conjugate.
The sum of a number and
its complex conjugate
is just the real
part of that number.
Then this h, this eigenvalue,
the system function
evaluated at j omeganaut, has
a magnitude and then angle.
If I write the system function
in terms of its magnitude
and angle, I can factor the
magnitude out of the real part,
and combine the angle by Euler
with the angle that generates
the cosine wave, j omeganaut t.
And I'm left with
my final answer,
that you can compute the output
as the magnitude of a system
function evaluated
as j omeganaut,
with a phase shift on the cosine
that's equal to the angle of h
of j omeganaut.
So this is the final answer.
If I want to think about
the frequency response--
if I want to think about how
this system has a response that
depends on frequency, I think
about the cos omega t going in,
and what comes out
is also cos omega t--
cos omega t.
Except the magnitudes change
by the magnitude of the system
function, and the phase
is changed by the phase
of the system function.
That's this thing I
said back on slide 2.
Sine in, sine out, however the
magnitude can possibly change,
and the angle, the phase
can possibly change,
but the frequency cannot change.
Omega went in, omega comes out.
OK?
So that leads to a very
easy way of thinking
about frequency responses, in
terms of pole-zero diagrams.
The idea is if you think
about the pole-zero diagram--
if the system can be represented
by a linear differential
equation with
constant coefficients,
then the system
can be represented
by a collection of poles and
0s, a handful of numbers.
How many poles are there,
how many 0s are there,
and where are they?
So if I have that
representation,
how many poles are there,
how many 0s are there,
where are they, I can think
about the frequency response
just by thinking
about the vector that
connects each pole and each
0 in turn, from the pole
and 0 location to the
point on the j omega
axis at the frequency
of interest.
So if I have a system
that has a single 0,
here I have a 0 at z
1, at s equals z 1.
Let's say that 0 is at the
point z 1 equals minus 2.
Single zero at the
point s equals minus 2.
Then I only need to
think about one vector.
If I'm interested in
the response for very
low frequencies,
very low frequencies
are at omega equals
0, I only need
to think about the vector that
connects the 0 to the point j
omega equals 0.
So j 0, which you
say is at zero.
So the eigenvalue is the
length of this vector, that's
the magnitude, and the angle of
this vector-- we always measure
angle relative to the x-axis.
So the angle of
this vector is 0.
So I get a magnitude
which is that big,
and an angle which is 0.
And that's plotted over here.
That's my result
for a low frequency,
a frequency close to 0.
Then if I think about a slightly
higher frequency, what happens
to the magnitude of the 0?
Bigger.
Bigger, it's the magnitude of
a 0, the 0s are in the top.
Bigger is bigger,
so the bigger arrow
translates to a slightly
bigger magnitude.
The angle that's
made with the x-axis
is now slightly positive, so
that's illustrated by the fact
that the angle is
deviating from 0.
And in general, I can think
about the frequency response
is just how the
length of this vector
changes as I change omega.
The change in length
tells me the magnitude,
the change in angle
tells me the phase.
Same thing happens
if I do minus omega.
What on earth is minus omega?
So omega was cos omega t.
Omega, right, it had to do with
how fast the motor was going.
What's minus omega?
Why am I drawing
minus omega here?
Yes?
Why am I interested in
these negative frequencies
that don't really exist?
Because I have an hour to
fill, and I don't have enough
stuff to fill the hour.
No.
Why am I interested in
negative frequencies?
I'm interested in negative
frequencies because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: --they let
me create sines and cosines.
Euler-- I invent
negative frequencies,
because I like complex numbers.
I like complex numbers,
because they're eigenfunction--
because the corresponding
complex exponentials are
eigenfunctions.
Cos omega t was not an
eigenfunction, I don't like it.
E to the j omega t is an
eigenfunction, I like it.
I invent negative frequencies
so that I can construct cos out
of the sum of two complex
things, one of them
happens to be this
imaginary frequency thing.
Who cares, it's just a
number, it's just math.
So in general, we will think
about positive and negative
frequencies.
Negative frequencies
don't exist,
we simply invent them
to make the math easy.
OK, so generally
speaking, because
of the complex
conjugate symmetry,
you can predict what
the negative frequency
part of the system
function will look like,
if you know the positive part.
So generally speaking, we'll
only look at the positive parts
when we know the
system is real, right.
This symmetry only comes about
when the system was real.
I proved it, because I knew
the h of t was real value.
OK, so now I can think about
the same sort of thing,
but this time with a pole.
The vector diagram
looks the same.
The shape of the
curve's upside down,
because the pole's
in the bottom.
Longer arrows now make
smaller eigenvalues.
So now as you go to
higher frequencies,
the idea is that a
single pole gives you
a frequency response,
whose magnitude
decays as you deviate from 0.
And you get
increasing phase lag.
You get increasing phase lag,
because this angle increases
with omega, but
it's in the bottom.
Increases in the bottom,
that means it decreases.
That's why the angle
goes down, in this case.
And if you have a pole
and a 0, the answer
is easily derived from
the previous two answers.
You think about two vectors, one
connecting the 0 to the point
at the frequency of interest,
the other connecting the pole.
And the magnitude is the product
to the lengths of those two
vectors, and the angle is the
sum of the angles of those two
vectors.
So you can see that the
0 is slightly shorter
at low frequencies, and becomes
asymptotically the same length.
That means that at
high frequencies
the magnitude goes to
1, except, of course,
I've got a constant
here, so it goes to 3.
And at low frequencies,
this length
is shorter than that one,
so it's slightly smaller.
The magnitude smaller
lower frequencies.
Similarly for the angles, the
angles both start out at 0,
so the angle starts out at 0.
If you go to a high
enough frequency,
both angles go 2 pi over 2.
So they both angle--
so the difference
goes to 0 at high
frequencies, as well.
There's a little
blip in the middle,
because the angle of the
zero increases more rapidly
than the angle at the pole.
0's in the top, so there's a
little blip for positive phase.
Same sort of thing works if I
think about the mass, spring,
dashpot system.
Now if I write the-- so if I
just write the differential
equation, figure out
the system function,
I get a simple form that
looks like so, second order.
If I imagine very
low damping, you
can see that the poles are
going to have the form s
squared m plus k must be 0.
So they are complex.
OK?
So if you factor this, if
you set this equal to 0,
you're going to get that
squared m plus k must be zero
if b were small.
So the poles are
going to be complex.
So for example,
if the poles were,
as indicated here, about
minus 1 plus or minus j 3,
all you do is the same
thing we did before,
consider the length
of the vectors,
consider the angle
of the vectors.
Here you get sum
product, and you
get angles that are
complimentary, so
plus and minus.
So the angle starts out at 0.
As you increase the
frequency, one of the pole--
one of the arrows
gets longer and longer
by about a factor of 2, and
the other gets shorter--
gets shorter by a lot
more than a factor of 2.
So that means that the product
of the lankes becomes small,
but they're in the bottom, so
the eigenvalue becomes large.
So that's what's going on here.
So that's the idea.
I've written two check
yourself questions.
Those are intended to just be
practice with complex numbers,
because you need to know
how to do complex numbers.
But the point-- so
the point of today
is just that there's a
very natural way-- that's
completely complementary to
thinking about convolution
in time.
There's a different natural way
to think about some systems,
in terms of the
frequency response.
How does the system respond
to an eternal sine wave?
It's a very easy
thing to compute.
It follows very
naturally from the things
that we thought about
with convolution,
and the results quite amazing.
The result is that the
magnitude of the angle
can be computed from the
Laplace transform of the impulse
response, which just happens
to be the system function.
So the point-- so
hopefully, what you see
is that we have lots
of representations,
and now we're seeing even
more connections between them.
OK.
Have a good day.